mes chers collègues nous entendons
maintenant Madame ségolen Royal qui est
ministre de l'écologie et du
développement durable et de l'énergie
depuis le 2 avril 2014 notre commission
d'enquête a été constituée sur un sujet
bien précis alors je rappelle à savoir
les mot ité du montage juridique et
financier et l'environnement du contrat
retenu
Infiné pour la mise en œuvre de
l'écotaxe poils lourd alors je précise
encore une fois que ce sujet est
différent de celui dont est saisi la
mission d'information de l'Assemblée
nationale qui elle s'interroge sur les
contours de la nouvelle écotaxe pour
financer les infrastructures madame la
ministre nous souhaitons nous avoir
votre analyse sur le contrat qui a été
signé nous allons vous interroger sur le
choix de la société Move pour mettre en
œuvre l'écotaxe sur le contenu de ce
contrat sur votre appréciation quant à
la conduite du projet par vos
prédécesseur nous souhaitons également
savoir quel est l'avenir de l'écotaxe et
du contrat est-ce que vous allez
maintenir l'écotaxe dans son principe
dans ses modalités allez-vous mettre fin
au contrat si oui comment déchéan
résiliation pour motif d'intérêt général
résiliation pour faute venant au contrat
poursuite du contrat voilà toutes les
questions que nous nous posons quelle
est votre solution finalement pour
régler la la la situation avecov et et
puis celle avec les banques alors compte
tenu du temps limité nous passerons
directement à une phase de question donc
vous connaissez déjà la la teneur je
vous informe que votre audition est
ouverte au public et et à la presse
qu'elle fait l'objet d'une captation
vidéo ainsi que d'un compte-rendu publié
je vous rappelle aussi conformément au
terme de l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du
du 17 novembre 1958 relative au
fonctionnement des assemblées
parlementaires votre audition doit se
tenir sous serment et je rappelle qu'en
cas de faux témoignage les personnes
entendues sont passibles des peines
prévues par les articles 434 13 434 144
et 434 15 du code pénal alors madame la
ministre prêtez serement de dire je vous
prie toute la vérité rien que la vérité
levez la main droite et dit je le jure
je le jure je vous remercie et je passe
tout de suite la question à notre
rapporteur madame Virg
NiCl merci madame la présidente madame
la ministre vous n'étiez pas au
gouvernement lorsque ce ce projet
d'cotaxe et et notamment le contrat avec
la société ecomov ont été signé
néanmoins j'imagine que vous êtes plongé
dans le passé pour que le futur soit
éclairé des lumières du du passé donc
dans dans un premier temps je
souhaiterais connaître votre
appréciation euh sur le choix de la
société ecomove et et sur l'ensemble des
choix technologiques qui ont guidé ce
contrat dans un premier temps à savoir
pas un système déclaratif pas un système
de vignett mais un choix technologique
et un contrat de partenariat public
privé avec la société ecomov pour mettre
en œuvre
l'écotaxe merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
de m'auditionner dans cette dans cette
commission merci oui d'avoir rappelé que
j'ai que bon je n'étais pas là au moment
de de la signature et de la mise en
place mais qu'aujourd'hui nous sommes en
effet dans dans une impasse et je suis
heureuse de voir que le Sénat s'est
saisi de de cette commission d'enquête
et que parallèlement l'assemblée
travaille également parce que je pense
que ces deux commissions vont éclairer
le gouvernement et vont m'aider à
prendre les bonnes décisions donc pour
en revenir très directement à votre
question euh la première curiosité c'est
le calendrier voilà une
réforme qui qui a été décidé à une
conférence environnementale de 2007 qui
a été votée dans une loi en 2008 le
Grenel alors que c'était une mesure
emblématique dont le contrat n'est
conclu que fin
2011 qui le contrat qui n'est pas
appliqué qui les portiques ne sont pas
construits donc on passe déjà de 2007 à
2011 et qui fait l'objet en plus d'un
décret du 6 mai
2012 fixant les modalités de
répercussion à un moment où d'ailleurs
le gouvernement aurait peut-être dû se
contenter d'expédier les affaires
courantes on découvre quand même que ce
décret fixant les modalités de
répercussion est pris de façon assez
précipité et en fait va déclencher les
événements en
Bretagne en effet ce dispositif très
technique reposé dans les grandes lignes
sur une répercussion au réel euh mais
nécessité des calculs à priori de
l'écotaxe généré par la prestation de
transport puis des calculs à postériori
de l'écotaxe réellement généré par la
prestation de transport en fonction des
trajets réellement entrepris avec des
règles de partage pour les transports
mélangeant plusieurs clients ce
dispositif a été considéré par les
transporteurs comme complexe très
insécurisant fragilisant leurs relations
commercial puisque nécessitant de
modifier à postériori le coût de la
prestation de transport il est vrai que
les transporteurs solidement organisés
avaient fait part dès 2010 de leur très
grande vigile à ce que le gouvernement
leur assure un dispositif leur
permettant de répercuter à leurs clients
c'estàd sur les chargeurs
lesécotaxes la crainte des transporteurs
était et toujours de devoir assumer une
partie de
l'écotaxe donc on voit bien qu'il y a
déjà une première perversion du système
puisqueà l'origine il s'agit de faire
payer par les camions le coût de l'usage
des infrastructures on découvre qu'avec
les modalités de répercussion ce sont
sont plus les camions qui vont payer
mais les chargeurs les producteurs de
fruits et légumes et
cetera à son arrivée le nouveau
gouvernement a souhaité concevoir un
dispositif alliance simplicité et
garantie pour les transporteurs
peut-être
insuffisamment prenant peut-être
insuffisamment en compte la sensibilité
pour les chargeurs sans doute exacerbé
en Bretagne le dispositif imaginé
reposer sur les principes suivants il
était calculé pour chaque région le
montant total de l' cota tax généré par
tous les transports de la région ce
montant rapporté au cumul de tous les
transports effectués dans cette région
permettait de calculer un taux unique
dans la région concernée et toutes les
prestations de transport dans la région
quel que soit le réseau utilisé sont
affecté d'une majoration sur la base du
taux calculé ceci est illustré par
l'exemple suivant en Bretagne il est
calculé que l'écotaxe généré en Bretagne
représente 45 millions d'euros ce
montant intégrant l'abattement de 50 %
dont bénéficie la Bretagne il est
ensuite mesuré que l'ensemble des
prestations de transport en Bretagne
représente 1200 millions d'euros il est
donc calculé que les cotaxes représent
en moyenne 3,7 % des prestations de
transport il est donc décidé que tous
les chargeurs paiont pour tous les
transports qu'il commandent une
majoration de leur facture de 3,7 % de
la prestation commandée ainsi pour cette
ces entreprises l'écotax se traduit très
simplement et très douloureusement par
une simple majoration uniforme de 3,7 %
de son budget transport donc on n plus
du tout dans le mécanisme de l'usage des
infrastructures les transporteurs ont
obtenu un dispositif sécurisant mais les
chargeurs mesurent que l'cotax se
traduit en fait pour eux par une simple
taxe sur les prestations de transport
comme s' avait été créé un tau
spécifique majoré de TVA sur l'activité
transport donc l'entreprise ecomov qui a
accompagné et conseiller
j'imagine le premier le gouvernement qui
a fait le décret du 6 mai 2012 puis
ensuite les adaptations pour essayer de
de trouver un dispositif doit également
rendre des comptes sur ce qui a été
imaginé alors qu'au départ c'était pas
du tout le le cœur du contrat parceque
le cœur du contrat c'était quand même de
faire payer les
transporteur donc la deuxième
observation c'est que on a quand même
quelque chose d'assez exorbitant dans ce
contrat puisque la
rémunération des fonds propres se fait à
hauteur de 17 % 17 % dans quel contrat
même d'association publique privée A-
ton un taux de
rémunération aussi élevé et j'ajoute un
coût de prélèvement de 25 %.
administration fiscales recouvre des des
prélèvements pour un taux bien moindre
et donc la question qui se pose pourquoi
donner à une entreprise privée le
pouvoir de percevoir une taxe à un coût
de prélèvement de 25 % avec une
rémunération des capitaux propres de 17
% est-ce que les intérêts de l'État ont
bien été défendus dans ce domaine et
j'ajouterai que le retard
apporté à la fois aux équipements à
l'installation des équipements puis les
rediscussions qui ont eu lieu avec les
transporteurs à compté de la signature
du contrat fin
2011 la remise en cause de ces contrats
avec le décret du 6 mai 2012 pour
répercuter la la taxe et donc pour
s'éloigner du dispositif initial a fait
subir à l'état etintérêt général un
préjudice considérable je dis cela parce
que quand j'entends parler du préjudice
des comov et des dédommagements à
l'égard descov dans cette discussion moi
je ferais valoir aussi le préjudice de
l'État et de toutes les collectivités
territoriales qui attend euh le
rendement de cette taxe pour pouvoir
faire les travaux donc il faudra à mon
avis avoir un raisonnement assez
équilibré sur quelle a été la
responsabilité des Comou dans ces
atermoimements dans ces délais et quel
est le préjudice aussi pour l'État donc
si un contentieux ou c'est une
discussion euh cette discussion ne devra
pas être
déséquilibrée au profit des comov car ce
qu'on découvre aussi en 3è lieu c'est un
problème d'opérationnalité il y a eu des
retard de la part de cette entreprise
sur les différentes installations et
surtout système qui coûte avant de
rapporter on sait combien ça coûte on ne
sait pas combien ça rapporte et j'ajoute
que dans le contrat il y a même pas de
sécurité sur le coût on dit 250 millions
d'euros le coût ensuite finalement c'est
plus cher on ne sait pas il y a dans le
contrat la possibilité aussi de calculer
le coût réel c'est-à-dire on on connaît
pas le rendement mais on est sûr de
connaître le coût des infrastructures et
et là aussi la question se pose de
savoir s'il n'y a pas euh un
déséquilibre
il semblerait également qu'il a des
problèmes du côté de la Commission
Nationale Informatique et Liberté
puisque
tout tous les les les roulants seront
enregistrés tout le monde sera
enregistré même ceux qui ne payent pas
la taxe et ensuite il y aura donc une un
calcul une sélection un enregistrement
de ceux qui devront effectivement payer
la taxe donc ça sera intéressant de
savoir pourquoi ce problème que soulève
la Commission Informatique et Liberté
n'a pas été vu par l'entreprise et
quelle solution technique il y a pour
protéger la vie privée des citoyens bref
la question que je me pose c'est de
savoir si ecomov n'avait pas présenté un
système un peu magique un peu magique
d'abord un taux de recouvrement de la
taxe de
99,99
% même avec la performance de nos
services fiscaux je ne sais pas si un
tel taux de
recouvrement des délais qui paraissaient
particulièrement en cours quant à
l'installation
d'infrastructure un rendement et un
dispositif technique qui paraissait
Simplicie alors qu'on se rend compte
qu'il est quand même extrêmement
complexe et enfin un dispositif dont
j'ai montré tout à l'heure la complexité
sur la Bretagne un dispositif de
répercussion qui n'est pas du tout dans
le mécanisme iniicial qui consiste à
appliquer le principe pollueur payeur on
n'est plus du tout dans ce
principe j'ajoute enfin que pour
terminer pardon d'être un peu longue
mais pour terminer sur ce sujet c'est
que je me suis interrogé sur la
sensibilité de l'opinion par rapport à
ces portiques donc j'ai regardé de près
parce que dans dans les dans les
territoires où les portiques avaient été
installés et ce qu'il faut quand même
souligner il y a parmi vous de nombreux
nous sommes des élus locaux c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de permis de construire
il y a pas de permis de construire pour
importique unortique c'est quand même un
objet assez agressif quand même donc
tout d'un coup sur certaines communes on
a vu apparaître des portiques le maire
n'était pas informé il y a pas de permis
de constr donc quand les citoyens voi
que pour modifier une façade ou mettre
une clôture il leur faut un permet de
construire et que là pour installer un
portique qui qui n'est quand même pas
anodin non seulement dans le paysage
mais dans ce cas ça représente
en terme de d'enregistrement des gens
qui passent sous le portique et même en
terme d'explication à l'égard de la
population des raisons d'être et cetera
on comprend qu'il y a eu des réactions
locales très vives sur cet objet non
identifié qui apparaissait sur les
territoires voilà un peu les éléments de
de d'appréciation du du
dispositif et maintenant la situation
c'est de savoir ce qu'on fait alors moi
j'attends aussi les j'ai pas de solution
miracle aujourd'hui je ne suis pas eov
donc je ne fais pas de miracle
mais j'attends beaucoup de vos
investigations de l'éclairage que vous
pourrez donner nous donner et puis aussi
de la Commission de de l'assemblée de
l'Assemblée nationale même si un certain
nombre de pistes dont on entend parler
aujourd'hui me paraisse
inconstitutionnel par exemple éliminer
certaines régions clour totalement la
Bretagne au nom de l'égalité devant
l'impôt ça me paraît absolument pas
facile on entend parler aussi de
régionalisation de de prise en compte
des spécificités agricoles mais ça va
être très compliqué sujet à contentieux
parce que quelle spécificité agricole ou
quel chargeur va être exonéré de la taxe
et en fonction de de quelle production
ça paraît compliqué la répercussion
qu'on appelle en pied de fact
jusqu'au GMS ne résoudra pas les choses
parce qu'elle sera
facultative qu'est-ce qu'on a imaginer
la régionalisation donc commence à
soulever des inquiétudes parce que là
aussi il y a un problème d'harmonisation
de péréquation de handicap
géographique et de
réalité et de réalité des besoins et ça
viendrait à pénaliser certaines régions
alors que sur les contrats de plan état
région sur le volet mobilité des
contrats de plan
on a besoin quand même d'une péréquation
et et d'une équité dans la répartition
de de cette
taxete non moi c'était juste sur le
Grenel de l'environnement que je voulais
revenir quand même sur le je trouve une
contradiction dans ce que vous dites
quand vous dites que on s'est éloigné du
système le Grenel l'environnement il
avait dit pollueur payeur et quand on
fait payer les chargeurs c'est le
donneur d'ordre c'est l'application
quand même de pollueurs payeur voilà
c'est la seule chose que je voulais sur
laquelle je voulais revenir mais sinon
madame le rapporteur
oui j'ai entendu que vous aviez pointé
un certain nombre de de de
responsabilités diverses dans la
nonacceptabilité aujourd'hui de
l'écotaxe et donc dans la suspension de
l'écotaxe qui est sans sans effet direct
en tout cas sur le contrat puisque
c'était c'était initialement pas prévu
vous avez pointé le calendrier vous avez
pointé aussi les PR préjudice pour
l'État et pas seulement les préjudices
pour ecomov et cetera donc tout ça me
semble-t-il sont des arguments qui
seraient des arguments de négociation à
faire valoir auprès d'comov donc dois-je
en conclure qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
plutôt sur une
posture de sortie de crise entre
guillemets en en négociant avec ecomov
un certain nombre d'avenant appelons ça
comme ça pour prendre un terme très très
vague au
contrat prenant en compte les
responsabilités diverses et variés des
uns ou des autres et et non pas une
sortie complète de l'écotax par exemple
via une vignette ou via une suppression
purédure et cetera mais d'être plutôt
maintenir le principe et et de voir
comment on l'amende ou comment on
modifie le contrat une fois de plus en
tenant compte de l'ensemble des éléments
et d'autres sans doute que vous avez
cité je pense que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour le pour le dire là j'ai signé le
principe d'une conciliation qui faisait
suite donc à la dénonciation par le le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc hraud mais je
n'ai pas désigné le
conciliateur parce que je souhaite lui
donner des instructions très précises à
partir des résultats de votre commission
d'enquête je ne vais pas parallèlement
la commission d'enquête donner demander
au conciliateur d'examiner tel tel tel
tel point si grâce à votre à vos travaux
on on voit émerger un certain nombre de
points sur les AEL il est désigné c'est
le mandat don c'est le mandat pardon est
dés pense Pier François racine est
désigné dés le mandat pardon c'est le
mandat qu'on a remis à ma signature sur
le mandat précis pardon et donc parce
que j'attendais le le le les conclusions
donc de de votre commission d'enquête
c'est nous donné une grande
importance euh selon vous vous vous avez
aussi d'ailleurs pointé le le c'est même
pu une transition c'est c'est presque
une opposition dans dans l'opinion qui
s'est faite entre le grand consensus du
Grenel de l'environnement et et sur le
le principe de l'échotaxe et puis le
refus aujourd'hui assez catégorique en
tout cas dans dans certaines dans
certaines zones de de la France donc
selon vous euh est-ce que cette taxe est
bien comprise comme une taxe écologique
ou est-ce que c'est devenu un peu une
taxe douanière ou est-ce que c'est une
taxe qui cumule un petit peu les
inconvénients de de ces deux types de de
fiscalité à savoir avec enfin alors
qu'elles auraient pourtant des des
principes différents euh entre la taxe
incitative le taux l'assiette et cetera
et cetera donc finalement cette cette
écotax aujourd'hui elle est
quoi d'abord le je crois que le terme le
terme taxe euh sous lesas ou le retour
même du mot écotaxe euh soulèvera les
mêmes oppositions parfois plus violentes
puisque comme je l'ai montré à partir de
l'exemple breton c'est finalement un
impôt généralisé de 3,7 %. donc on est
très loin euh de de la redevance on est
très loin du du péage routier donc il me
semblerait qu'il faut réfléchir sur une
logique de péage routier comme il y a un
péage des autoroutes pour emprunter les
autoroutes il faudrait donc un péage des
routes qui ne sont pas payantes et
notamment pour les transporteurs non pas
étranger mais venus de l'étranger
c'est-à-dire qui sont effectivement
majoritairement des constructeurs
étrangers donc pour les constructeurs
qui passent les frontières qui prennent
les routes qui traversent la France en
transit et donc qui ne payent rien qui
ne payent même pas la TIPP parce que on
on connaît les pratiques de plein fait
en Bretagne on traverse tout et de plein
fait en Espagne a donc là un vrai
problème c'està-dire que ces
transporteurs ne contribuent absolument
pas à l'entretien des infrastructures
routières
ou très peu donc en tout cas ceux qui
ceux qui ne font cela ne contribuent pas
donc la première question est de savoir
si on peut trouver un système qui permet
de faire un péage non pas une écotaxe
générale et massive mais un péage pour
les les les transporteurs qui
transiteraient à travers le pays afin
qu'il contribu aux
infrastructures la deuxième chose c'est
est-ce que le dispositif financier et
technique tel qu'il est là peut être mis
à
plomb c'est très compliqué vu l'ensemble
des des démonstrations des éléments que
j'ai don tout à l'heure c'est quand même
très compliqué et en plus il y a une
déperdition de rendement qui n'est pas
accept enfin qui difficilement
compréhensible dans un contexte de
restriction de de la dépense publique
même si c'est 250 300 millions d'euros
par an c'est quand même proportionné par
rapport aux besoins d'infrastructure
oui dans dans ce coup justement le le
contrôle et les exigences de l'État vous
avez cité par exemple tout à l'heure le
taux de recouvrement de
99,75 % on PESIT un poids assez lourd
donc comment voyez-vous
aujourd'hui ce poids euh de l'État en en
terme d'exigen de contrôle de taux de
recouvrement enfin exigen
fiscal oui parce que le taux de 99 %
c'était pas eomov qui qui avait décidé
c'est l'état les douanes pour leur pas
les cité qui avaient imposé cette ce
niveau de de recouvrement donc du reste
bien supérieur à celui qui qui a été
demandé en Allemagne par exemple hein
voilà c'esté un taux très élevé mais
c'est pas ecomov ecomov ne faisait que
répondre à un cahier des charges dans
lequel on l'obligait sur tout oui ils
ont répondu au C donc ils sont déclarés
quand
même disponibles et compétents pour
assurer ce taux de recouvrement ils
peuvent pas choisir après géométrie
variable c'est vrai ce sur quoi ce sur
quoi ils ont accepté sans discuter puis
ceux qui sont ce qui sont capables de
faire ça c'est c'est c'est c'est
l'équilibre et le contenu du contrat oui
mais puisqu'on est justement aujourd'hui
en train de de parler de de revoir ce ce
ce contrat éventuellement en tout cas d'
faire des avenants ou de modifier les
choses c'est c'est une des question
quefin qu'on se pose est-ce que on peut
envisager est-ce que vous envisagez
éventuellement à ce que certaines
exigences de l'État soit revu un petit
peu à la baisse pour rendre aussi le
système plus acceptable et peut-être
moins coûteux aussi et tout aussi
efficace dans l'aspect incitatif il y a
forcément des des
arbitrages politique me semble-t-il à
avoir en en de façon à bien redéfinir un
peu plus à cette taxe ses objectifs
est-ce que c'est une taxe douanière ou
est-ce que c'est une taxe
écologique donc est- est-ce que ce genre
de de
réflexion est aujourd'hui envisagé non
pour l'instant non parce que je
considère que l'État est quand même
subit le principal préjudice de tout ce
dispositif les collectivités
territoriales qui attendent des des
travaux
également donc je ne vois pas comment
l'État pourrait abaisser ses exig parce
que sinon ça remet en cause alors la la
crédibilité et la concurrence qui a eu
lieu au moment de l'attribution du du
marché du contrat donc l'État ne peut
absolument pas
unilatéralement abaisser ses ses
exigences ou alors ça voudrait dire qui
reprend le contrôle de l'ensemble du
dispositif la question qu'on peut se
poser c'est combien de temps on peut
rester comme ça voil une bonne question
quand même on peut poser cette question
parce que quand
même demand la mise position hein l'État
avait 2 mois pour répondre c'était avant
votre désignation hein mais l'État avait
jusqu'au 20 mars quelque chose comme ça
pour répondre sur la mise à disposition
et aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
j'allais dire presque préconentieuse
quand même hein voilà nous on a vu à 8
clos les banques on a vu eomov on a vu
les représentants de des ministères euh
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut pas
rester quand même comme ça dans une
situation voilà donc est-ce que moi j'ai
envie de vous demander quand même est-ce
que vous avez chiffré le à combien vous
estimez le coûte pour l'État euh de la
suspension certes la perte de recette ça
bien sûr mais est-ce que vous avez
chiffré au-delà de la perte de recette
le coûte pour l'état de de la suspension
de l'écotaxe parce
que Ben le dédommagement l'application
du contrat moi je l'appellerai
application du contrat parce que quand
on suspend lescotaxes le contrat lui il
n'est pas suspendu il se poursuit et
donc il y a des des clauses d'échéance
rés pour faute résiliation pour pour
intérêt général et ca pénalité de retard
et cetera donc ça ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de savoir si l'état quand même a
estimé ce
coûte un peu de quelques idées mais
c'est la conciliation qui va permettre
ça en intégrant dans la conciliation le
préjudice de l'État parce qu'il y a
quand même un problème d'opérationalité
de la part de l'entreprise de délais qui
n'ont pas été
respectés de confor
orbité à la loi au principe de de la
Commission Nationale Informatique et
Liberté donc il y a quand même un
certain nombre de problèmes qui ont été
un peu occultés quand même par
l'entreprise sans doute bon c'est bonne
guerre pour obtenir le le contrat mais
cet entreprise devra aussi rendre des
comptes dans le cadre de la conciliation
et puisque tous ces atermos et tous ces
délais et tous ces
dysfonctionnement sans parler de la
sous-estimation de de la réaction
populaire au tout comme j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure du minimum de correction
vis-à-vis des élus locaux c'est quand
même la moindre des choses
qu'unentreprise qui installe une
infrastructure de ce type prenne contact
avec les maires donc tout cela a fait
aussi que dans la la la façon même de se
comporter de l'entreprise il y a eu un
préjudice très important puisque ça a
retardé le le dispositif donc moi ma
question c'est question c'est au nom de
la commission si vous voulez c'est que
nous notre commission d'enquête elle
doit remettre impérativement comme vous
le savez son le 27 mai puisque nous on a
des délis contraints de 6 mois donc
est-ce que je dois comprendre que le
mandat ne sera pas remis au conciliateur
à cette date et que nous serons donc
dans une situation
probablement toujours d'attendre vous
avez bien compris moi j'ai pas donné de
mandat au consiliateur alors que vous
êtes en train de
travailler mais probablement donc au 27
mai il n'y aura pas eu de d'accord et
vous pensez que les banques vont tenir
bon rester comme ça sans sans exiger
quoi que ce soit à ce momentl on
rentrera dans une négociation dans un
contentieux mais si on rentre dans un
contencieux moi je ferai valoir le
préjudice de l'État parce qu'on parle
toujours du préjudice de l'entreprise
jamais du du Pr de l'intérêt judice de
nous tous des défenseurs de l'intérêt
général et des défenseurs de l'État donc
s'il un contentieux on ira au
contentieux donc je pas s que
l'entreprise sera en position de force
dans un cont chaque parti a désigné son
conciliateur et les deux con iateur
devait en désigner un 3è ce 3è a été
désigné il il a pas été désigné
encore voilà parce que voilà pour vous
tout vous dire Madame la Ministre ce qui
était pas très clair c'est de savoir si
nous sommes vraiment dans une dans une
période de conciliation ou si c'est
encore une période de négociation parce
qu'on comprend bien que tout le monde a
peut-être intérêt à négocier l'État a
certainement intérêt à négocier mais et
commou aussi donc voilà notre notre
question c'est de savoir parce que nous
on va être obligé d'arrêter nos travaux
sous peu et je pense que on a'ura pas
donc les les réponse à à cette question
est-ce qu'on est vraiment dans la
conciliation ou est-ce qu'on y est pas
on est dans la dans de bonnes
disposition dans la mesure où nous avons
désigné un conciliateur que le
conciliateur déconciliateur c'est
Monsieur laptou euh donc il peu ils
peuvent commencer à se
parler il peent toujours se parler mais
le mandat précis que je dois donner au
conciliateur il n'est pas donné par et
la mise à disposition n'est toujours pas
actée par le par le gouvernement mise à
disposition
matériel parce qu'en fait la demande
elle a été faite le au mois de janvier
ça fait partie de la
conciliation pe toujours pas proncer
d'accord c'est ce qui nous avait été dit
d'ailleurs à la dernière l'audition
qu'on avit eu examiner solution si
madame le rapporteur veut accepte que je
donne un peu des questions à nos
collègues monsieur Teston a demandé la
parole pardon-moi il est là merci madame
la présidente madame la ministre je
souhaite vous poser deux questions que
je vais formuler le plus succintement
possible d'abord dans la perspective à
mise en place de l'écotaxe poids lourd
le gouvernement Fillon a semble-t-il
fixer la taxe à les chieux au niveau
minimum ce qui constitue depuis lors une
importante perte de recettes pour l'État
pouvez-vous confirmer si effectivement
tel est bien le cas et la deuxième
question vous avez évoqué la question de
la taxation des poids lourds venu de
l'étranger j'ai bien noté qui circule en
France et quand on analyse la situation
on constate que les transporteurs
français pai la TIPP alors ma question
est la suivante serait-il possible de
mettre en place un dispositif permettant
de compenser le fait que les
transporteurs venu de l'étranger ne pe
pas la
TIPP qui vous le savez pe peut sétablir
mais dans des conditions extrêmement
strictes mais c'est toutes ces
investigations là qu'il faudrait faire
l'eurovignette qui d'ailleurs adopté par
certains pays européens n'est possible
que si il n'y a pas de d'autres péages
d'usage d'infrastructure par exemple
l'Allemagne puisque les infrastructures
les autoroutes sont gratuites nous le
problème c'est que comme on a la fois
des autoroutes p payantes et des routes
nationales qui ne sont pas payantes
l'idée quand même c'était qu'une partie
de ces camions prennent les autoroutes
euh que que on puisse quand même
négocier l'urovignette pour les camions
qui n'allaient pas prendre les
autoroutes puisque donc ils utilisent
une infrastructure non payante et que
une incitation soit donnée au camions
pas à tous les camions parce qu'on
aurait aussi une saturation des
autoroutes donc faut aussi un équilibre
des des flux de camions de d'ù la
difficulté que si une partie des camions
du coup payit alors qu' qui n'utilise
pas aujourd'hui les autoroutes étit
contraint de prendre les autoroutes sous
un certain nombre de conditions en
régulant bien le flux général et cetera
à ce moment-là on avait euh on aurait
une augmentation du chiffre d'affaires
des autoroutes et donc pourquoi pas un
reversement euh de ce chiffre d'affaires
plus une négociation complémentairire
pour que euh une partie des des des des
des résultats des autoroutes soit
consacrés aux équipements des
infrastructures alors je vais donner la
parole à Monsieur Doliger s'il veut bien
et et ensuite à d'autres collègues et je
vous demanderai de répondre à toutes les
questions parce qu'ils sont très
nombreux à vouloir vous interroger hein
voilà donc je vais donner j'ai pas
forcément réponse à tout hein parce
qu'il y a des mais si mais si on
espère madame la ministre madame la
Présidente pardon euh d'abord juste
peut-être un petit complément
d'information si vous le permettez vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure la sensibilité
de l'opinion et des mares qui étaient
pas prévenus je dois vous dire que
c'était pas dans le cas de mon secteur
géographique et que là où les portiques
ont été installés que les maires ont été
largement prévenus avaient reçu les
plans avaent eu des demandes
d'autorisation d'implantation et que
nous avons eu des longues négociations
pour les emplacements à mettre dans
leurs communes avec les maires et avec
la société ecomov donc je pourrais vous
donner les noms les adresses les
communes et cetera donc ça s'est très
bien passé en tout cas dans notre
secteur géographique euh mais peut-être
que c'est part d'c comme vous avez
témoigné je témoigne dans mon secteur ça
s'est très très bien passé ça a pris du
temps mais ça s'est particulièrement
bien placé je je je lisais un un
compte-rendu d'une réunion qu'a eu
Xavier bin avec le Premier ministre et
ils ont évoqué le sujet donc Xavier
Belin président de la
FNSEA et Monsieur Manuel Vals a dit
quant à l'cotaxes il a indiqué entre
parenthèses enfin entre guillemets le
système précédent serait complètement
donné et que seggolen royale Madame
seggolen Royale l'article c'est un peu
rapide était en train d'ouvrir une
réflexion sur une remise à plat du
dispositif donc mes questions vont être
un peu par rapport à
cette annonce du Premier ministre
d'abord confirmez-vous l'abandon complet
puisque il est dit dans l'article entre
guillemets que le le système était
totalement abandonné en quoi consiste la
remise à plat y a-t-il un délai parce
que ce que l'on souhaite tous c'est que
bien sûr il a une sortie de de ce
dossier et mon inquiétude comme celle de
beaucoup et et la votre certainement et
de voir que ce dossier traîne et depuis
longtemps avec des couts bien évidemment
donc on a parlé de la vignette vous AES
parlé de de la vignette maintenant vous
parlez de de péage nous aimerions savoir
comment on peut sortir de cette
situation puisque vous avez parlé des
des
responsabilités alors effectivement il y
a des négociations qui qui s'engagent
avec une conciliation mais des
responsabilités à mon avis dans une
négociation elles seront partagées alors
plus ou moins d'un côté que de l'autre
bien évidemment mais elles seront
partagé et derrière il y a
des des interlocuteurs qui sont
directement concernés vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure les collectivités et les
collectivités vous avez dit pour les
travaux qui ne sont pas réalisés jeis
vous rappeler également que les
collectivités étaient bénéficiire de
recette donc il faut penser que dans
les difficultés que rencontre
les collectivités c'est pas seulement
les travaux non réalisés mais ce sont
les recettes qui est également quelque
chose
d'important
euh voilà globalement ce que je
souhaitais vous poser par contre sur le
problème de la tax simplement là aussi
une petite précision vous nous avez dit
la taxe il faudra changer le mot en
phage ou autre chose je vous rappelle
que quand on a eu l'autorisation
d'augmenter les droits de mutation qui
est une taxe on nous a dit qu'une taxe
était pas grave c'était pas un impôt
donc que finalement on pouvait très bien
appeler une taxe une participation
financière enfin je pourrais vous citer
des interventions du précédent
gouvernement quand il nous a permis
d'augmenter les DMTO que c'était pas
grave parce que c'était qu'une taxe donc
simplement entre la taxe l'impôt et le
péage bon je crois que c'est un sujet
qui peut faire partie de pas mal de
discussions ce qui m'intéresse c'est
est-ce qu'on abandonne ou pas François
gridier on va pas êre dans le temps on
va pas y arriver il y a beaucoup de
monde qui vous demande à vous interroger
et bien merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre donc moi aussi
j'aurais voulu savoir en quoi consistait
une remise à plat une remise en cause je
sais ce que c'est une remise à plat on
comprend pas si encore le dispositif
était en vigueur et qu'on décide au bout
d'un certain temps de regarder ses
qualités ses défauts et de faire des
ajustements com le terme de remise à
plat mais là j'aurais voulu vous
expliciter ce ce point effectivement
cela a été compris et interpr traité
comme un abandon général alors j'ai noté
un beaucoup de de contradictions dans
dans vos dans vos propos
d'abord les contradictions sur les
délais on parle à la fois de retard et
de précipitation en fait quand on l'a
fait dans cette commission et qu'on voit
comment a pu être appréhendé à la fois
par les partenaires privés et par les
services de l'État ce dossier
effectivement il y a un certain nombre
d'éléments de complexité il y a des
retards négociés et en même m temps tout
le monde était assez pressé que le
projet aboutisse et quand vous attribuez
au au caractère très précipité du
dernier décret les émeutes en Bretagne
dire je crois que des observateurs très
neutres ont quand même considéré que ces
émeutes étaient provoqués par un ralbol
fiscal cette taxe s'ajoutant en fait à
beaucoup d'autres et non pas par le
dossier descotax lui-même qui avait été
très fortement négocié à la fois avec la
FNTR et à la fois avec les représentants
de de Bretagne ensuite j'aurais voulu
savoir ce qui pour vous compte tenu de
vos dernières déclarations eu euh un
dispositif incitatif ou un dispositif
punitif parce que je croyais jusqu'à
présent qu'on était dans le punitif en
matière d'environnement comme ailleurs
quand on posait une réglementation des
interdictions et que si celle-ci était
violé qu'on sanctionné or le principe
même de l'écofiscalité c'est
l'incitation et là je comprends pas non
plus votre réflexion sur votre
étonnement plutôt sur le fait que ce
soit répercuté sur les chargeurs c'est
que le le propre de l'écofiscalité est
intégré les coûts environnementaux dans
le prix de revien donc dans le prix de
vente justement pour que par exemple la
viande qui vient de d'animaux élevés en
Bretagne puisse finalement n'arriver pas
plus cher dans le rayon d'hypermarché en
étant traité en Bretagne jusqu'au
conditionnement plutôt que comme c'est
le cas aujourd'hui d'être transporté les
animaux sont transportés vivants de
Bretagne en Allemagne
où ils sont abattus où les carcasses
redescendent parfois en Europe du Sud
pour être transformé en épicerie fin
espagnool ou italienne et revenir dans
nos hypermarchés et lorsque les camions
descendent ils évitent
soigneusement l'Allemagne et la Suisse
qui taxe justement le transport et non
pas le travail et et utilise quoi nos
autoroutes et nos routes nationales et
départementales en Moselle en Alsace sur
le sillon sur l'assau sur le rô et ou ou
souvent en ayant fait le plein au
Luxembourg ou en Allemagne en polluant
notre air en abîant nos routes et sans
rien payé or la suspension du dispositif
continue au préjudice de ces régions
frontalières mais aussi à au préjudice
de la Bretagne parce que c'est quand
même assez curieux que la réponse du
gouvernement héros à la fermeture de
l'abattoir gade hein qui est justement
le départ en raison de la délocalisation
de l'aval de la filière agro alimentaire
ce ce soit conclu par l'abandon de cet
échotax qui avait justement vocation à à
relocaliser les activités alors euh
j'aimerais que vous précisiez votre
pensée à la fois sur euh euh et bien
euh je crois qu'elle était pas très
aboutie je crains que les conclusions de
la commission d'enquête parlementaire ne
soi pas la hauteur de vos espoirs sur le
fait que l'État puisse s'exonérer de sa
responsabilité financière à l'égard des
comov en cas d'abandon du projet pour
cause d'un intérêt général c'estàdire
pour de décisions politiques
deuxièmement il faut il faut conclure
alors alors deuxiè sinon on va pas y
arriver bon alors ensuite on pose la
question posée par le le premier
intervenant les les les les les
transporteurs français ont bénéficier de
la réduction de la taxe à les cieux en
anticipant lescotaxes ils ont
aujourd'hui le beurre et l'argent du
beurre on peut aller plus loin
effectivement sur la TIPP qu'il verse
chez nous euh euh mais euh ça fait pas
mal de questions productif bon donc
alors je terminerai j'en avais d'autres
sur le point je termine quand même parce
que en évoquant la situation là où eomov
devait s'implanter c'est-à-dire dans
l'agglomération messcine si je doute pas
un instant qu'ecomov soit soit indemnisé
quand sera-t-il de l'agglomération
médecine qui devait recevoir ses emplois
en compensation des restructurations de
la défense et que vous avez en plus site
que vous avez sanctionné cette semaine
encore en refusant le projet solire qui
devait s'implanter sur le même site donc
c'est madame la Présidente pour ne pas
j'auris d'autres questions je
m'arrêterai là pour la Paro auè
d'ailleurs on pour aussi s'terroger sur
les 130 douaniers qui ont été embauchés
aussi pas que
sur transfér mais il y a eu forcément
des effectifs qui ont augmenté alors je
redonne la parole à Louis Nère et puis
peut-être que je vais vous laisser
répondre sur ce point là parce que je
croisautement on va pas y arriver ou y
en a beaucoup d'autres encore madame la
ministre bonjour il y a un premier
problème qui est apparu à travers votre
déclaration un peu à l'emportepèce en
disant on remet tout à plat ceux qui ont
travaillé sur ce dossier depuis quelques
années et qui ont pris vous avez eu
raison de rappeler qu'il faut remonter à
2017 2007 ceux donc qui attendaient
comme dans d'autres pays que cet écotax
puisse être installé ont été un peu
surpris de cette position là mais au
bénéfice d'inventaire et sous réserve de
savoir qu'est-ce que vous vous allez
mettre à la place alors j'ai bien
compris que pour l'instant tout le monde
cherche vous aussi et l'idée d'un pH
s'inscrirait sur les routes qui ne sont
pas aujourd'hui payantes bon pourquoi
pas sauf que j'attire votre attention
sur quelque chose qui est apparu c'est
qu'une de vos propositions c'est de dire
on va faire payer les
étrangers délicat délicat j'attire votre
attention politique sur le fait qu'à un
mois des
européennes nous et un ministre comme
vous puisse dire ah les étrangers vont
payer et pas les Français moi j'ai peur
que ça favorise finalement un peu côté
si vous me permettez le terme démagogie
et Front national attention j'attire
votre attention là-dessus si vous dites
je pénalise les camions
étranger où est l'Europe où est l'Europe
alors on se bat depuis des années
alors donc je vais je vais aller plus
vite voilà je vais aller plus vite si
maintenant vous souhaitez envoyer
davantage de camions sur les autoroutes
qui pent une surtaxe j'attire votre
attention dans le midi de la France et
notamment dans les Alpes Maritimes dont
je suis originaire nous avons d'ors et
déjà 600000 poids lourds qui passent sur
l'autoroute à 8 et ça fait un véritable
massacre de la région si en plus on
injecte les autes on a déjà des murs de
camion ça va devenir quoi à ce moment-là
on aura d'autres problèmes donc moi je
vous ai fait passer je vous ai saisi je
vous ai saisi aujourd'hui même d'une
proposition de Philippe mjard qui est un
spécialiste des transports et qui
utiliserait le décret du 24 octobre 2011
relatif à l'information sur la quantité
de dioxyde de carbone émise à l'occasion
d'une prestation de transport les trans
f plus dans notre périmètre cher Louis
sont obligés mais nous avanons fauton on
va avancer parceous avançons pour
essayer de trouver une solution
d'intérêt général dans laquelle le
pollur soit c'est pas notre commande
dans la commission d'enquête donc moi je
vais qu donner la parole à Monsieur
Roland DC s'il veut bien oui donc je
vais je vais essayer d'être court et de
rester effectivement sur le sur le sujet
je
m'engage moi moi j'entends de des
paroles de de Madame la Ministre un un
début de continuité de l'action de
l'État et ça me ça me rassure plutôt
c'est-à-dire que je crois qu'on est très
nombreux à penser ici que le terme
écotax c'était le pire terme possible
alors que c'est fondamentalement une
redevance et que le terme phéage routier
est plus pr est plus près de ce qu'est
déjà l'idée même de
l'écotax tel que nous avons tenté parce
que c'était un nou assez consensuel en
fait à un moment de de la mettre en
place euh donc euh ma question c'est de
dire est-ce que finalement euh l'État
n'est pas en train d'essayer quand même
de trouver une certaine continuité euh
entre ce qui a été fait depuis euh un un
certain nombre d'années en intégrant
évidemment les blocages actuels euh euh
réels et en restant sur une logique de
phéage routier qui est bien une logique
globalement de taxe clinométrique et
d'usage de la route au au réel en
essayant de se rapprocher du réel et et
j'entends j'entends même je vais
peut-être trop vite en musique peut-être
l'idée d'aller encore plus vers le réel
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement une des
difficultés qu'on a eu mais ça a été
très clair dans les auditions que moi
j'ai pu faire en tant que rapporteur du
du budget des routes c'est que cette
idée de de pied de facture qui qui
finalement distort un peu le réel par
rapport au fait de dire voilà vous avez
fait tant de kilomètres à tel endroit et
ça vaut tempant c'est quand même les
transporteurs on même presque pour mieux
dire la FNTR qui qu' a négocié en en
échange de son soutien à la mise en
place de de de l'écotaxe donc est-ce que
vous essayez aujourd'hui d'essayer
d'avoir un système encore plus proche du
réel et puis du coup le dispositif
ecomove après une une renégociation des
retards mais là-dessus je doute pas que
s'il y a une continuité d'utilisation du
dispositif il y aura un accord euh à ce
moment-là c'est d'aller vers plus de
réel et avec du coup quand même dans les
questions le fait de dire est-ce que
vous avez une idée de la manière dont
les transporteurs pourraient l'accepter
pu estce que c'est eux qui ont imposé le
pied de facture c'est pas l'idée de
départ et donc est-ce que ça fait partie
des pistes sur lequell vous vous
travaillez aujourd'hui ce qui
commencerait à nous donner vraiment une
vision de d'une sortie de crise possible
et on aurait perdu globalement un an de
fonctionnement ù est-ce que vous allez
plus loin dans la dans dans dans la
remise en cause du du système allez
comme les questions se recoupent tout un
peu monsieur capo Candela merci Madame
la la présidente madame la ministre vous
avez eu tout à l'heure un propos
liminire qui était roboratif euh qui
avait la mérite de la franchise de la
clarté peut-être pourrions-nous nous
interroger sur ensembre de précision que
vous avez donné on sera quand même
d'accord sur le point de départ vous
nous dites aujourd'hui nous sommes dans
une impasse de ce point de vue-l je
crois que chacun sera d'accord la
question c'est votre propos où est-ce
qu'il nous conduit pour sortir de
l'impasse j'ai retenu aussi la
conclusion qui était dispositif pe
difficilement être remis à plomb bon
donc vous nous avez livré une analyse
brillante critique violente quand même
qui est de dire que finalement de tout
ça rien n'est bon c'està-dire que le
système de l'écotaxe ne peut pas être
retenu qu'il faut passer à autre chose
don tact j'avais compris au sein de la
commission sans trair de secret que il y
avait une autre option qui était de
renégocier avec ecomov au mieux des
intérêts de l'État et au mieux de
l'objectif écologique de départ qui
était favorisé le report modal et que
cette option là elle pouvait tenir
lacorde visiblement vous l'écartez vous
l'écartez avec la charge que vous avez
donné tout à l'heure qui éta bryante un
peu violente quand même mais est-ce que
vraiment c'est l'option du gouvernement
aujourd'hui est-ce qu'on est clair
là-dessus est-ce que la négociation qui
n'a pas commencé sous la forme de
conciliation là-dessus j'admire madame
la rapporteur qui en vous écoutant avait
conclu à la conciliation par que vous
avez commencé un peu haut dans la
négociation c'est normal c'est la règle
du jeu mais j'entendais pas forcément la
notion de conciliation mais est-ce que
vraiment on écarte toute idée de
compromis avec ecomove est-ce qu'on part
de l'idée qu'on met les cotax par terre
est-ce que c'est ça le ce qu'il faut
retenir de votre propos et dans ce
cas-là comment l'État s'en sort-il parce
que du point de vue financier on peut
remettre ça à plus tard mais visiblement
il y a quand même un risque financier
fort qui se livre qui se compte en
centaines de millions d'euros pour
l'État et puis deuxièmement comment
assurer l'objectif écologique le
financement de la fit qui est un sujet
budgétaire pour cette année et qui pose
un certain nombre de questions voilà ce
que je voulais revoir un peu avec avec
vous parce que faire payer les
autoroutes et puis éventuellement faire
payer sur les autres routes pourquoi pas
mais comment ça va marcher quand comment
et surtout comment vous sortez du
système actuel vous le condamnez mais
c'est quand même un peu facile que veut
rajouter Raymond
Val il est pas là il est parti Philippe
Leroi Philippe tu veux rajouter quelque
chose un mot simplement je voudrais
rappeler que cet écotaxe a été voté je
crois sur tous les banc politique c'est
un un vœu national et je suis un peu
étonné que
cela a été voté assez récemment il y a 2
ou 3 ans par tous les bans politiques et
puis on voit l'adhésion à cette idée qui
était accepté unanimement l'adhésion à
cette idée se délitait simplement parce
que les transporteurs ont Rous péé parce
que les agriculteurs ont vousous pété
parce que chacun a cherché à démonter le
système et on se rend compte que la
continuité de l'État dans cette affaire
dans la fermeté nécessaire d'un état
n'est pas assuré ça a été voté par tout
le monde sans
discussion il faut bien le rappeler et
en 3 ans les difficultés
euh ont conduit à faire en sorte que
plus personne ne ne soutient un système
qui pourtant me semble indispensable
deuxièmement Madame le Ministre la
question je pose est quand même claire
voulez-vous concilier parce
que votre annonce tout à l'heure ça m'a
un peu
troublé d'indiquer que la rémunération
du capital
apporté est de 17 % et que la
rémunération du des frais de
recouvrement est de 25
% j'aimerais une note précise sur cette
affaire parce que en démarrant sur ces
bases la la le principe de la
négociation que vous proposez va être
beaucoup plus
compliqué euh qu'une simple négociation
technique et des adaptations mineures
pour rassurer telle ou telle catégorie
de euh de de euh socio-professionnel ou
tel ou tel territoire euh vous avez
placé la mise très haut comme disait le
dernier interlocuteur et et et
j'aimerais là euh que qu'on soit euh sûr
de ce qu'on dit parce que 25 % de taux
de rémunération sur le capital et 17 %
fait plus enfin l'inverse oui peu
importe peu importe les les de me
semble nécessairement il faut en
reparler ça a été dit et ça ne peut pas
être caché cette affaire là parce que ça
ressortira donc j'aimerais qu'on ait une
des précisions vraiment précise sur
cette affaire très bien Roland ris va
terminer cette Selve de question merci
beaucoup l'essentiel a été dit mais
madame la
ministre j'ai été rapporteur de ce
projet de loi et j'avoue que je
n'imaginais pas un seul instant qu'on en
viiendrait à la situation qu'on
d'impasse que l'on connaît aujourd'hui
au moment où on a eu la discussion
parlementaire d'autant plus que il y a
il y avait un large consensus sur le
principe ça a été un peu plus discuté
quand même sur les modalités pratiques
il faut faut quand même dire qu'on a eu
on a eu le débat mais je naurais pas
imaginé qu'on a qu'on arrive à ce ce
résultat d'aujourd'hui et euh mon souci
à moi c'est qu'on puisse en en sortir et
j'imagine que c'est le souci de de de
tout le monde ici
alors deux choses à dire la première sur
l'objet de notre madame la Présidente je
vais essayer de rester dans le sujet sur
l'objet de notre travail je suis
maintenant convaincu que le système qui
a été mis en place est un système
perfectionniste qui coûte très cher et
qui
Infiné me semble-t-il pas n'était pas
nécessaire mais on en est là aujourd'hui
on a des contrats avec ecomov et et ca
et je suis convaincu
que se fixer comme objectif un taux de
recouvrement de
99,5% on aura peut-être fait 95 % on
aurait fait du déclaratif on aurait fait
je sais pas une vignette que saisje ça
aura été sûements très différent mais
ENF on en est là il reste et c'est
l'essentiel à mon avis comment on en
sort il y a que de deux façons d'en
sortir deux façons d'en sortir la
première c'est de corriger le système
c'est de d'amender le système alors
est-ce qu'on peut je sais pas moi
travailler sur le tonnage ce qui était
prévu dans dans la préfiguration
alsacienne c'était des camions de 12
tonnes et et au-delà là on est à 3
tonnes5 est-ce qu'il faut travailler
là-dessus je n'en sais rien oou est-ce
qu'il faut travailler
sur des des circuits courts enfin donc
amender le système et corriger au fond
ces imperfections pourquoi
c'est une possibilité peut-être l'autre
hypothèse c'est on abandonne le système
avec évidemment les conséquences
financières qui sont derrière parce
qu'il va falloir
évidemment indemniser comov même si il
peut y avoir peut-être
une une négociation ça coûtera de
l'argent et si on va dans ce sens-là
qu'est-ce qu'on met à la place qu'est-ce
qu'on met à la place si on veut vraiment
que
cette ce péage pour poids lourd
appelons-le ainsi se mettre en place qui
est à mon avis souhaitable est-ce qu'on
fait un système déclaratif est-ce qu'on
fait un système à la Suisse avec des
vignettes ou
ou autre chose mais il y a que ces deux
hypothèses là où on corrige le système
tel qu'il est en
l'amendant en le perfectionnant ou on en
sort et on en fait un autre avec des
conséquences et c'est les deux les deux
hypothèses alors j'aimerais savoir si
aujourd'hui vous êtes au clair là-dessus
merci Roland pardon mais voyez toute
vraiment la commission attendait
beaucoup de votre audition madame la
ministre donc je vous laisse le soin de
d'essayer de répondre à l'ensemble de
nos collègues ah donc vous me gâtez avec
toutes ces questions je ne sais pas si
je vais répondre à tout donc monsieur le
le sénateur d' liig donc abandon remise
à plat euh c'est une question de
vocabulaire parce que c'est la le vrai
mot c'est la suspension donc aujourd'hui
on est dans dans une situation de
suspension qui a été décidée d'ailleurs
par le gouvernement pas par moi donc moi
je je je gère cette situation là donc il
y a une suspension avec l'idée de remise
à plat parce queand quand il y a une
suspension B on regarde les solutions la
remise à plat c'est pas c'est pas une
déclaration Tony truante là comme l' dit
l'un d'entre vous c'est géris d'une
solution où j'ai une suspension du
dispositif je regarde je remets à plat
avec votre aide et avec l'aide de la
commission de l'Assemblée nationale
alors vous avez dit aussi 1660 millions
oui que c'était aussi un manque à gagner
pour les collectivités vous avez
parfaitement raison parce qu'il y a des
portique sur certaines routes
départementales à la demande de certains
conseils généraux qui devait rapporter
160 millions d'euros donc c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un un vrai sujet c'est pour
ça qu'il faut qu'on trouve une solution
monsieur le sénateur grosidier moi je
veux pas
polémiquer polémiquer avec vous hein
c'est vrai c'est vrai que la loi était
votée à l'unanimité mais vous savez on a
vu dans l'histoire d'excellents
dispositifs théoriques et puis être
confronté au processus d'application on
peut pas non plus ignorer ce qui s'est
passé dans dans le pays et la réactivité
par rapport à ce problème ce qui est
important dans une dans une fiscalité
écologique c'est qu'elle soit comprise
par les citoyens accepté par eux et
qu'elle servent à faire évoluer les
comportements parce que c'est ça aussi
le fond du problème c'est que
normalement une fiscalité écologique
c'est pas seulement obtenir un rendement
VO qu'il a eu un déséquilibre du
dispositif il est surtout là pour
raorter de l'argent pour faire les
infrastructures ce qui est tout à fait
louable mais quand même même le deuxième
pilier d'une fiscalité écologique c'est
de changer de comportement et et d'avoir
des comportements moins polluants or le
le le le le gars honnê qui qui a un
transport qui produit vous ctiez les les
producteurs de Bretagne ou ceux qui qui
qui gèent les les les les productions
animales il demanderaiit que ça que de
mettre leurs produits sur le fret mais
il y a pas de de de transport alternatif
il y a pas de transport donc
effectivement c'est une taxe c'est un
impôt puisqu'il y a pas de transport
alternatif et même le dispositif qui
consiste à répercuter sur le producteur
fait que même quand il met sa cargaison
sur le train par que ça on m expliqué ça
le producteur de choufleur même quand il
met sa production sur le train il va
payer lesécotaxes dans le système actuel
donc on est quand même dans un système
qui est devenu totalement absurde au fur
et à mesure de la réadaptation en
fonction des des rapports de force des
uns et des autres donc si je voulais
polémiquer ce que je n'ai pas fait je
dirais quand même qu'on pardon cette
expression mais une drôle de patate
chaude entre nous parce qu'elle a quand
même été votée non pas il y a 3 ans mais
il y a 6 ans et c'est aujourd'hui qu'on
doit quand même gérer le la question moi
je vais pas je polémiquerai pas je dir
pas c'est la faute de ceux d'avant je
pense qu'on a à résoudre un problème
pour aujourd'hui et pour demain et plus
on sera astucieux collectivement pour
trouver une solution mieux ça sera pour
l'intérêt général parce qu'on pourra
signer les volet mobilité des contrats
de plan état région et donc engager les
travaux et donc créer des emplois et
donner du travail à nos entreprises de
de travaux publics monsieur le sénateur
Louis Nère donc oui vous avez dit que je
je j'avais fait des déclarations la
porte-pièce on remet tout à plat non
c'était une façon de dire on va regarder
comme intelligemment les choses puisque
j'ai un système de de
suspension vous avez évoqué aussi le
problème de des camions étrangers alors
peut-être que mes propos ont été un peu
ramassés c'est les camions venus de
l'étranger si bien évidemment il y a des
camions français qui passent la la
frontière mais la la la majorité des
camions venant de l'étranger sont
étranger d'ailleurs c'est le dispositif
qu'a adopté le Royaume-Uni et qui a
adopté euh l'Allemagne donc c'està-dire
c'est-à-dire l'eurovgnette c'est-à-dire
l'eurovignette aux frontières qui a un
coût du coup de de de de gestion et de
prélèvement beaucoup moins important je
vais revenir tout à l'heure qu'un
système qu'un système de de portique
diffusé sur l'ensemble du territoire
national avec la réserve que j'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire dès lors
qu'on a des des autoroutes payantes
c'est compliqué de de mais peut-être que
là il y a quelque chose à rechercher
parce que il est quand même très étrange
que les autoroutes qui ont été qui ont
été privatisés dans le contexte que l'on
connaît j'y reviens pas fasse quand même
2 milliards de bénéfices et que ces 2
milliards de bénéfices qui sont quand
même payé par les usagers ne reviennent
pas pour payer les infrastructures dans
le cadre des contrats de plan ettat
région c'est une vraie question donc je
pense qu'une partie de la solution peut
peut-être se poser de ce point de vue-là
pour rien vous cacher on a commencé à
quand même à contacter les les
actionnaires de sociétés autoroutière
parce que si quand même on arrive à
prélever une partie maisant la moitié on
arrive au rendement de l'écotaxe sans
aucun frais de recouvrement et sans
aucun financement d'entreprise privée
sous réserve des problèmes des emplois à
mes effectivement qui ont été à juste
titre évoqués mais ces entreprises qui
sont actionnaires des des sociétés
autoritières sont les entreprises de
travaux publics ce sont les mêmes qui
vont bénéficier des travaux que nous
ferons sur nos territoires dans le cadre
des contrats de plan état région qui
sont actionnaires des autoroutes donc
peut-être y y
a-t-il un espace de négociation dans le
cadre d'une intelligence collective et
d'un partenariat intelligent pour que
une partie quandme de ces profits au
lieu de rémunérer les actionnaires de
façon abstraite soit réintégré dans le
dispositif de recette dont on a besoin
pour financer des chantiers routes
autoroute tramway et cetera qui vont de
toute façon constituer le chiffre
d'affaires des mêmes entreprises qui
sont actionnaires des autoroutes donc
pour ne rien vous cacher ce sont des
contacts que nous que nous avons pris
pour essayer de voir s'il y a quand même
pas là une piste pour réorienter un
certain nombre de financement
autoroutier vers ce qui nous préoccupe
c'est-à-dire vers l'investissement des
infrastructures
routière ferroviaire et de transport
propre en
ville donc monsieur le sénateur DC oui
le péage
routier oui s'il y a des changements
importants l'idée même le fondement même
du texte est bon d'ailleurs il été voté
à l'unanimité l'idée de dire bah voilà
il y a un droit d'usage sur les routes
comme il y a un droit d'usage sur les
autoroute c'est imparable et avec ce
droit d'usage c'est imparable sous
réserve du petit déséquilibre que j'ai
évoqué tout à l'heure c'est-à-dire que
l'idéal aussi serait qu'il ait des des
transports alternatifs à la route plus
moins plus écologiques ce ce qui n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui mais s'il y a des
changements importants il faudra
naturellement renégocier la la totalité
du dispositif ou alors trouver un
dispositif un peu à géométrie variable
c'està-dire une part de prélèvement à la
mia parce que moi je je pense que tout
tout engagement sur quelque chose de
législatif de contraignant va être très
long et ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on
puisse engager rapide les travaux dont
les régions je bien placé pour le savoir
j'ai signé en tant que présidente de
région le volet mobilité du contrat de
plan et ta région donc je je sais que
les entreprises là attendent les
chantiers les travaux qu'on en a besoin
et qu'il faut commencer les chantiers ça
c'est ma principale priorité c'est de
trouver les moyens financiers pour
commencer les chantiers d'infrastructure
donc si on peut dégager une partie des
résultats des autoroutes en discutant
avec elle de façon intelligente la façon
dont on peut prélever les choses si on
peut mettre une part partie des aut des
camions qui sont aujourd'hui sur les
routes qui saturent les routes sur la
National dis que je connais bien sous
réserve de ce que vous dites qui est
très vrai parce que j'ai regardé de près
il faut pas non plus resaturer des
autoroutes saturées donc ça ça sera
peut-être possible sur un certain nombre
axes notamment les axes de transit
Nord-Sud si un certain nombre de portiqu
aux
frontières finalement équivale à une EUR
vignette c'est-à-dire taxe
prioritairement les camions étrangers
puis qu'il y a un certainom une dizaine
je crois de de portiqu aux frontières
qui qui cible les camions venus de
l'étranger ça ça peut être aussi une
petite une recette complémentaire donc
l'intuition que j'ai pour l'instant
c'est avec une série comme ça de de de
de discussion qui qui qui complète les
choses où l'on prend que l'aspect
positif de chacune de ces mesures on
peut peut-être arriver un paquet
financier global qui dès lors qu'il y
aura plus le coout du recouvrement et la
garantie de rémunération des des
capitaux propres par que on sera dans un
système à ce moment-là bah contrôler
gérer maîtriser pourra peut-être
équivaloir à peu de choses près tout
dépend de la capacité de négociation du
rendement
attendu de
l'écotaxe alors monsieur le
sénateur j'arrive plus à relire monsieur
Canella
pardon cap
excusez-moi bon alors vous vous avez dit
que j'ai j'avais misis une critique
violente de l'échotax est-ce qu'on
écarte toute idée de négociation non je
pense qu'on écarte pas toute idée de
négociation parce que même on a désigné
des conciliateur donc au contraire c'est
je pense c'est en regardant les les les
les différentes propositions imaginable
que l'on peut peut-être trouver une une
solution et j'ai j'ai j'ai pas condamné
à a priori moi comme je disais tout à
l'heure j'ai une situation lescotax est
suspendu et je vois la réactivité on a
vu tous ensemble la réactivité des des
citoyens du dispositif compliqué je
pense que ça très compliqué de faire un
dispositif à géométrie variable c'est
dans dans certaines région pas dans
d'autres des régions mises sous pression
si elles mettent les cotax je sais pas
si l'Alsace par exemple pourrait décider
toute seule de mettre lescotax que sur
l'Alsace je suis pas sûr que les
citoyens ou que les
transporteurs mais voyez je je pense pas
a priori se réserve de vérifier que si
l'État se désengage en disant bah aux
région bah débrouillez-vous on
régionalise lesécotaxes que ça soit un
grand cadeau fait aux régions parce que
d'abord elles sont dans des parce que
c'est c'est une solution que j'entends
moi ça me paraît de la je ne me sens pas
faire ça vis-à-vis des régions qui vont
se trouver quand même dans des
situations très différentes des
sensibilités très différents des
structures des des entreprises de
transport très différents des des charge
des du chiffre d'affaires des chargeurs
très différents donc ça me paraît quand
même assez compliqué mais bon sous
réserve d'examens
complémentaires Monsieur L roi donc ben
je comme je disais tout à l'heure c'est
pas il y a de ou 3 ans mais il y a 6 ans
et je vous confirme bien que dans le
contrat il y a 17 % de de rémunération
des des coûts de des capitaux des
capitaux propres et en ce qui concerne
la
collecte en ce qui concerne la collecte
il y a en effet 25 % du cout de la
collecte puisque
euh la le rendement était prévu était
1,160 milliards d'euros millions
milliards d'euros et le coût de la
Collette c'est obamo parce qu'après on
nous a dit Comou faisait entendre
laisser entendre que ça serait
finalement plus cher donc dans le
contrat c'est 270 millions d'euros à mon
avis c'est un peu sous-estimé mais même
avec ce ce quota indiqué de 270 millions
d'euros le coût de la collecte c'est 20
25 % qu'est-ce que ça veut dire 25 %
c'est que le rendement de la taxe 25 %
des travaux n'existe sont manger il a il
y a les travaux du rendement de la taxe
moin 25 % alors que si vous avez voyez
si vous avez un système de de rgette ou
un système de péage comme sur une autre
voyez il
a bah oui mais quand même tax est plus
élevé sur tax était plus élevé ça ferait
moins oui ça c'est sûr et c'est terminé
madame la ministre sera peut-être un peu
plus difficile bon euh monsieur le
sénateur Roland ris euh oui en effet il
faut essayer de d'amender le le système
c'est le rôle de de la Commission de de
Jean-Paul chandgay à l'Assemblée
nationale donc je j'attends aussi le les
conclusions de cette commission pour
voir comment on pourrait effectivement
remettre en place un un dispositif alors
je ne sais pas si la phase d'observation
en Bretagne finalement a donné en en
Alsace puisque ça devait êre expérimenté
en Alsace sans recouvrement de la taxe
pour le tester est-ce qu'à partir de de
cette expérience vous avez des
propositions ou si il y a eu des
observations qui pourrai nous permettre
d'évaluer un certain nombre de choses on
l'a pas fait finalement renoncé
parce elle é prép préparation sur la
base de 12 tonnes effectivement camion
12 tonn c'était la 12 tonn mais comme la
priode expémentation était de de moins
de 6 mois on on a décidé à l'unanimité
de d'abandonner cette expérimentation
mais la demande existe en Alsace parce
que il y a un fort report de trafic
depuis la mise en place de la M
allemande de ce côté du RIN donc on est
demandeur voilà madame la
présidenteci exuse-moi si je n'ai pas pu
répondre à tout non mais c'était très
difficile de répondre tout le monde on a
compris quand même madame la ministre
que vousêes ê davantage sur lescotaxes
que sur le contrat nous nous avons
compris ça nous nous sommes plus sur le
contrat c'est notre c'est notre mission
et moi j'ai quand même envie de vous
poser une dernière question au nom de la
commission
c'est encore une fois moi je vais rester
sur le contrat parce que c'est notre
c'est notre champ d'investigation est-ce
que de votre point de vue puon a parlé
responsabilité est-ce que la
responsabilité pour vous elle est sur
eove ou elle est sur le cahier des
charges
quand on regarde les problèmes qu'il y a
est-ce que c'est le cahier des char
c'est un PPP un contrat avec des
dispositions complexe compliqué est-ce
que c'est ça ou est-ce que c'est la
personnalité la société qui a répondu
qui qui a été choisi et qui
estove madame la Présidente ça m'est
difficile de répondre à cela parce que
je n'ai pas eu connaissance des offres
j'ai pas eu le temps de regarder de
faire de la rétrospection sur les offres
de des entre ise ou de l'entreprise
concurrente donc c'est peut-être en
comparant les offres et la réalisation
de ces entreprises dans dans d'autres
pays que vous pourrez peut-être avoir la
réponse à cette
question jouer le jeu dans C
commissionquête merci beaucoup mes chers
collègues nous entendons à présent
Monsieur Christian secrétaire d'État au
budget depuis le 2 avril 2014 monsieur
le ministre nous avons souhaité vous
auditionner pour connaître la manière
dont sont géré budgétairement la
suspension de l'écotaxe po lourd et le
contrat écomov
euh comment comptez-vous compenser la
perte de ressources pour la fit pour
l'année 2014 les collectivités
territoriales ben est-ce qu'elles vont
être compensées du fait de de la
suspension qui résulte d'une décision
unilatérale de l'État est-ce que vous
avez envisagé toutes les conséquences
budgétaires des différentes hypothèses
de sortie du contrat laquelle vous
paraît la plus adéquate euh en cas de
faillite des COV lié à l'exigibilité de
la dette par les banques et à l'absence
de versement de de loyers est-ce que
vous estimez est-ce que vous avez estimé
le coûte d'un plan social voilà voilà
tout un tas de question qui que nous
nous posons je vous informe que votre
audition est ouverte au public à la
presse qu'elle fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo ainsi que d'un
compterendu publié je vous rappelle que
conformément au au articles au terme de
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires votre
audition doit se tenir sous serment euh
je rappelle également qu'en cas de faux
témoignage les personnes entendues sont
passibles des peines prévues par les
articles 434 13 434 14 434 15 du code
pénal donc monsieur le ministre je vous
demande de prêter serment de dire toute
la vérité riè la vérité de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure alors je le
jure merci euh vous pouvez si vous le
souhaitez nous présenter peut-être un
court exposé liminaire on va fixer ça à
5 minutes si vous êtes d'accord à la
suite duquel le rapporteur Virginie
Cless et puis les autres membres de la
commission moi-même on vous posera des
questions en comme vous voulez si vous
voulez faire un petit exposé ou si vous
voulez qu'on démarre directement sur les
questions
je sur votre proposition je je ve faire
un petit exposé liinaire si vous le
permettez en en vous remerciant de de
votre accueil et en vous disant bien
entendu je me'fforcerai de répondre à à
à l'ensemble de vos questions avec deux
bémoles le premier c'est que euh ça
c'est uniquement factuel vous vous savez
que j'ai accédé à mon poste il y a très
peu de jours et avec une actualité
particulièrement chargée et brûlante
donc je n'ai pas peut-être complètement
pris la mesure du dossier euh et le
deuxième c'est qu'un certain nombre
d'informations euh sont couverts par par
des procédures de secret euh soit secret
des affaires soit le secret fiscal mais
que je me ferai bien entendu un point
d'honneur de répondre par écrit à des
questions qui seraiit de cette nature à
ce moment-là dans les formes
habituelles pour permettre de respecter
ces questions couverte par le le secret
prof des affaires ou ou le secret fiscal
je je vais être bref en essayant de
respecter les 5 minutes que vous
m'accordez euh je sais bien sûr que
votre commission se consacre avant tout
à faire la lumière sur le montage
juridique et financier retenu pour la
mise en œuvre de l'écot taxe je
rappellerai rapidement néanmoins les
origines de la taxe elle-même c'est une
nouvelle étape dans la fiscalité
écologique du pays et elle trouve son
origine comme vous le savez dans dans le
Grenel de l'environnement elle a été
décidée par une précédente majorité
euh et
compte tenu de la très large
concertation a pu être adopté par le
Parlement de façon
transpartisane elle a bien sûr une visée
écologique même avec un taux
relativement faible on est autour de 30
centimes d'euros par kilomètre elle doit
inciter néanmoins à des comportements
plus rationnels de l'usage du réseau
routier en encourageant bien sûr le
report modal ce qui est un objectif je
crois partagé sur beaucoup de bands de
nos